I was talking to my husband the other
day about why I'm interested in making
money versus why he is and he said he
always liked expensive things basically
I didn't want to feel vulnerable anymore
from not having enough money and so my
yearn to be successful was always so
that I would be less vulnerable so that
when I had a problem I had money to help
me solve it and that was my motivation
that was also my motivation to get a
social media following because there was
negative articles coming out about Dad
and then there were negative articles
coming out about me and I didn't have a
platform to fight back and I thought if
I have a platform and a media article
comes out then I can tell people my side
of the story and I'm not as vulnerable